hey it's Matt code checking tutorials
game development why is this so goddamn
hard why is every game ever broken why
does every game have so many bugs
you know this is this is a real question
that needs a real answer because
you know it's it kind of blows my mind
in a way so let me explain my train of
thought here and
try to explain why game development is
so hard sure make a little basic easy
gait that's really rigid like Tetris is
not that hard there's no there's just
little defined movements you can only go
in certain spaces and that's it so games
like that are really simplistic to build
compared to other ones like take Ark
survival evolved for example we ever
play that game you won't like it I mean
it's super cool and you do a lot of cool
stuff but you won't like it because it
shows all the problems with modern game
development they're all in that game and
the problems they have they're pretty
much in every game like it
it's it's almost strange to me that
game development is the hardest job in
the world and it's by no stretch that
there's a harder job
now you might be thinking oh what about
people who work on
I don't know
well maybe maybe it's paralleled with
something like let's let's think about
let's think about going to another
planet living there we haven't been able
to figure that out you know what else we
haven't been able to figure out how to
collide objects how to make two objects
in a program collide we haven't figured
that out every game is really really
buggy unless it's a really rigid system
like Tetris or some game like that any
other game every 3d game cannot figure
out how to make 3d objects collide
properly three accesses X whatever X Y Z
and objects running into each other it's
it's a complete anomaly that
millions millions and millions and
billions of dollars of funding can't
figure out
programming it's the hardest job game
programming is the hardest job in the
world just based on that alone I mean
that's just one thing there are other
things too oh you want to shoot an arrow
you're gonna shoot a bullet oh look you
just shot an arrow you hit somebody and
it didn't register the game's broken
20:19 people still don't know how to
program people still don't know how to
math
when will we figure it out well it'll be
approximately the same time we figure
out I live on another planet is it like
the same challenge rating
more I think about this the more it
annoys me and the more I want to figure
it out more I want to fix these broken
systems and that's one of the reasons I
keep pushing on that's one of the
reasons
I don't give up I want to see this
through I'm tired of this broken
colliding crap
I just want to play one game where it's
not broken and I think the only way I'm
going to do that is if I build it I'm
quite convinced to this
and even if I build it I'm sure it's
gonna broke it but maybe eventually I'll
get there so this is that's like my
lifelong goal at this point is to build
a 3d colliding system in game with zero
bugs zero colliding bugs things actually
work as intended isn't even possible
based on the previous results of all
other 3d games ever made it's not
possible you will be able to somehow
warp and glitch through walls and doors
every game you will find some little
loophole where you can speedrun up a
wall in and cut the game time in half in
every single game
that's better how much time they spend
on the development it doesn't matter
what John what year this latest 3d sweet
Zelda game was built in someone will
find a way where it's just completely
bonkers program it's way too hard I
guess that's why I like it like
challenges alright well just a just a
fun rant what do you guys think about
this is it true is there any game where
there is no colliding bugs that
specifically a 3d game maybe even a 2-d
game seniors have been 3d or that's
impossible for people to actually build
anyway that's it it's been mad ko-teng
tutorials smash the like button it helps
my channel and the YouTube algorithm to
do
my videos and subscribe to see more
videos about programming from a
programmer also some random life tips
and hit the bell if you want to get
notifications peace out Kico